NOW, MOVIES BEGIN WITH A
SCREENPLAY, EITHER AN ORIGINAL
STORY OR ONE ADAPTED FROM
PREVIOUS WORK.
AND AFTER SO MUCH ISOLATION, WE
WANTED TO GET TO KNOW OUR NOMINEES
SO, HERE ARE A FEW THINGS
WE LEARNED.
THE WRITER/DIRECTOR OF
"JUDAS AND THE BLACK MESSIAH,"
SHAKA KING -- THAT'S MY COUSIN.
IT'S NOT, BUT IN
MY HEAD, HE IS.
HIS FIRST MOVIE JOB WAS
AN EXTRA ON A FILM CALLED
"30 DAYS," DIRECTED BY
JAMAL JOSEPH,
A FORMER BLACK PANTHER.
AND FOR CO-WRITER
WILL BERSON,
BEING THE OFFICE MANAGER
FOR JOHN LEGUIZAMO'S
LOWER EAST SIDE FILMS STOKED THE
FIRE IN HIM TO TELL HIS STORIES.
AND FOR CO-WRITER KENNY LUCAS,
WATCHING "CITY OF GOD" IN
COLLEGE INSPIRED HIM TO BE A
FILMMAKER INSTEAD OF GETTING A
PHD IN PHILOSOPHY.
AND HIS
BROTHER KEITH LUCAS WAS
IN LAW SCHOOL WHEN HE
REALIZED HIS LOVE OF FILM.
LEE ISAAC CHUNG,
WRITER OF "MINARI"
WHOSE FIRST FILM JOB WAS
PRODUCING EDUCATIONAL FILMS
IN NEW YORK,
REMEMBERS SEEING "E.T."
FOR THE FIRST TIME AS A CHILD.
STANDING UP WIDE-EYED IN THE
MOVIE THEATER THE ENTIRE TIME.
THAT IS SO ADORABLE.
OH.
AND EMERALD FENNELL, GIRL.
YOU TOOK TIME OFF FROM PLAYING
CAMILLA BOWLES IN "THE CROWN" TO
WRITE, PRODUCE, AND DIRECT
"PROMISING YOUNG WOMAN”
WHILE YOU WERE SEVEN MONTHS
PREGNANT DURING A 23-DAY FILM SHOOT.
GIRL, YOU EARNED THE
TITLE OF THAT FILM.
DARIUS MARDER SUPPORTED
HIS TEN-YEAR JOURNEY TO MAKING
"SOUND OF METAL" WITH A
SUSHI CATERING BUSINESS IN VERMONT.
HIS CO-WRITER BROTHER,
ABRAHAM MARDER
WAS A MUSICIAN AND COMPOSER.
AND CO-WRITER DEREK CIANFRANCE'S
FIRST JOB WAS A FRIEND'S GET
RICH QUICK SCHEME FILMING DOGS'
FACES TO PUT ON COFFEE CUPS
CALLED PUPPY MUGS.
DEREK, LET ME GET ONE OF THOSE MUGS.
YES.
AND AARON SORKIN, WRITER/DIRECTOR
OF "THE TRIAL OF THE CHICAGO 7"
HE STARTED HIS CAREER IN MOVIES
BY RIPPING TICKETS
AND MAKING THE POPCORN
IN HIS NEIGHBORHOOD THEATER.
SEE, YOU NEVER KNOW, THE GUY
SERVING THE POPCORN COULD BE
THE NEXT AARON SORKIN.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
EMERALD FENNELL,
"PROMISING YOUNG WOMAN”
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
OH, MY GOSH.
OH, THEY SAID WRITE A SPEECH.
AND I DIDN'T, BECAUSE I JUST
DIDN'T THINK THIS WOULD EVER
HAPPEN, AND I'M GOING TO BE
IN TROUBLE WITH
STEVEN SODERBERGH.
I'M SO SORRY.
I DON'T WANT HIM TO
BE CROSS WITH ME.
OH, MY GOD, HE'S SO HEAVY
AND HE'S SO COLD.
SO THE ONLY SPEECH I EVER
WROTE WAS WHEN I WAS 10.
I HAD A LOOK TO SEE IF THERE
WOULD BE ANYTHING USEFUL FROM IT
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, I MOSTLY
THANKED ZACK MORRIS
FROM "SAVED BY THE BELL," WHO WAS
MY VERY SUPPORTIVE HUSBAND.
UNFORTUNATELY, HE HASN'T BEEN AS
MUCH A PART OF MY LIFE AS I'D HOPED.
AND SO THAT SPEECH
IS NOT THAT USEFUL
BUT ALL I CAN SAY IS, TRYING
VERY HARD NOT TO CRY,
WHICH IS VERY DIFFICULT
AS AN ENGLISH PERSON
BECAUSE YOU DON'T CRY EVER.
THIS FILM WAS MADE BY THE MOST
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE IN THE WORLD,
WHO MADE IT IN 23 DAYS
AND BROUGHT THEIR COMPLETE
GENIUS AND LOVE AND HUMOR TO IT.
AND I HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE TO THANK.
I FEEL MORTIFIED THAT
I'M HERE BY MYSELF
WHEN IT'S NOT JUST MY
JOB AT ALL.
I WANT TO THANK CAREY MULLIGAN,
FOR BEING NOT ONLY THE MOST
TALENTED PERSON IN THE WORLD,
BUT THE KINDEST AND FUNNIEST.
I WANT TO THANK THE PRODUCERS
FOR STANDING BEHIND THIS FILM ALWAYS
AND YOU KNOW NEVER GIVING UP.
AND LUCKY CHAP, FOCUS,
FILM NATION,
THE CAST AND THE CREW, THE
GREATEST IN THE WORLD,
THE KINDEST IN THE WORLD.
THEY JUST MADE ME LOOK GOOD.
AND AGAIN, I'M JUST SO GRATEFUL.
FINALLY, MY FAMILY.
MOM, DAD, COCO.
OH.
MY HUSBAND, CHRIS.
COME ON, COME ON.
OUR SON, WHO DID NOT ARRIVE
UNTIL A COUPLE OF WEEKS AFTER
SHOOTING, THANK GOD, BECAUSE I
WAS CROSSING MY LEGS
THE WHOLE WAY THROUGH.
SO, THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH.
STEVEN, I HOPE THAT
WAS ALRIGHT!